they make up half the population but as
these girls grow up their voices seemed
to disappear just over one and five MP
is a female and this election could
change the face of Parliament launching
their women's manifesto at a South
London nursery labour say 2015 will be a
breakthrough they've selected female
candidates and fifty-three percent of
target seats we're hoping that after the
general election will have a hundred and
fifty label women MPs and I think that's
important it not only changes the face
of Parliament so you don't just see only
men sitting on those green beige benches
it actually changes the agenda as well
Labour's infamous pink bus aims to reach
out to the 9 million women who didn't
vote at the last election but away from
the organised photo ops is politics
really cutting through in Brixton
politicians are in their manifestos
appealing to us at creating policies to
benefit definitely to not vote not
choose a candidate based on
they rot away because it's nice to have
a good balance i think the leader of dsm
feature shows they're actually women can
are quite important I think he's no
points they will the same anyway after
Mays election more women than ever are
set to make it through the door into
Parliament a record 1022 women are
standing one in four candidates in 2010
though 143 women MPs elected that was
twenty-two percent of the total makeup
of parliament now the electoral reform
Society has suggested that will get to
thirty percent women MPs that's a
significant increase but I think we
ought to be mindful that that's still
just thirty percent and women are fifty
two percent of the population so I think
we need to be careful that historically
we're coming from very low numbers of
women MPs it's hard to talk about female
voters without resorting to cliche not
all women care about childcare for
instance some more worried about the
economy but if you're dealing in
generalizations then women are more
likely to be undecided and that is why
they matter to politicians female voters
were at the center of this week's party
manifestos with the Conservatives
doubling free childcare the lib dems
pledging use it or lose it shared
parental leave and you keep promising
tax free childcare for the under-12 but
i think it's about creating the right
kind of environment to encourage women
to say you know this can be for you you
know many women juggle family life
they've come from professional careers
themselves where the professional
working day is slightly different to the
you know life of being an MP we're not
only do you work in parma but you have
to manage constituency life and you have
to manage two bases your westminster
base as well as your constituency based
you gotta juggle all of that there will
be progress at the election but it will
be a baby step at the current rate of
change a child born today will be
drawing her pension before she sees
equal numbers of men and women in the
house of commons safety Ridge Sky News
South London